you
I noticed that it's just you right now
do you go by Mitchell or Mitch either or
Mitchell sir
okay I'll just I'll go with Mitch is the
last names in Moffit separately Moffitt
sorry about that um so you know I like
how just I just ask before I hit record
I noticed that uh your partner Gregory
Brown that he's not with you and then uh
why is that yes so he actually we
started the project together we're both
from the Toronto area in Canada and he's
actually a teacher and got a job abroad
in the UK so he's teaching there for the
year um so we still work on them sort of
together writing them and researching
but generally I do sort of the video and
the audio stuff here now that he's gone
very cool very cool
let me see you know about the whole I'll
just jump right into the whole video and
audio how did you come up with that
artistic style that you use the idea of
doing a whiteboard kind of sped up with
those animate with the illustrations
yeah I had sort of been brought into
like the YouTube culture recently I had
some friends who were doing YouTube
different types of things but then it's
kind of got more and more into it and I
come across some other channels that
sort of have a similar format so I have
seen the whiteboard stuff before in
particular a channel called RSA animate
and they kind of turned lecture series
that are like ten minutes ten minutes
long and make them a bit more engaging
by having some but they animate them I'm
seeing that and new that was like
especially effective for me and I
thought that was kind of a really cool
method to to translate education into
because this constant movement you're
not just staring at somebody talks the
whole time and so I just thought that
was really cool method there are some
other channels out there that are doing
a similar thing and I think they work
really well because it becomes less
about the person and more about the
message and like the the whatever the
particular video is about so you know if
my face isn't in it then you know it's
kind of just about what you're learning
about it came from yeah that's that's
really interesting actually and then I
mean to get to like the whole inception
of the channel how did you come up with
the idea for the YouTube channel you
know just a chant or the idea of a
channel dedicated to explaining science
in a fun way how did that come about
right well I
look Greg and I were both pretty
passionate about science we both did a
degree together in BIOS I and he had
like a minor in studio art and we were
constantly telling our friends like the
coolest parts of science and trying to
sort of inspire them into like liking
science cuz we know we're both mixed
interests like I'm in the arts as well
and and video and musicals and stuff so
I had a lot of friends who were
interested in it and so we realized you
know people would like to learn about
this sort of popular science and so Greg
was in Teachers College at the time when
we started thinking about you know how
can we you know interest people in this
particularly like the youth demographic
who there seems to be a sliding away
from or at least there's been lots of
reports on you know kids kind of failing
out of high school at a higher rate and
interest in science kind of dropping but
I was seeing you know YouTube and seeing
some videos that were completely science
related that we're getting millions of
views and I was like okay this is
obviously there's a demand for it and
there's people who are willing to learn
about it and so perhaps it's more about
how it's being delivered so we just kind
of started thinking you know we love
science so much and we think we can put
you know interesting topics to kind of
hook people in and then hopefully you
know they'll go into further learning
and into further science if they can
kind of get hooked by these interesting
aspects that are kind of circle
surface-level
and then they'll be more interested down
the line so yeah we just slowly started
the ASAP science Channel generally with
just sort of things we had learnt either
in school or cool science facts that we
had known and then it slowly evolved
into people suggesting ideas and
commenting and kind of creating and
joining a community of like wanting to
learn about science so that is kind of
how the ball got rolling that's that's
really cool that's really interesting
actually I like that you talk about how
you know you interacting with the
community it's a good idea I think
that's a really important part of like
what makes it different from you know
not only television but sort of standard
educational platforms like in school it
is more of a conversation and people can
feel like they're part of it and then
there's also the shareability part where
people can then go and teach other
people or even just post it on their
Facebook or Twitter just sort of feel
like that part of that teaching process
and we have people on Facebook and on
our YouTube comments that are actively
trying to help answer other people's
questions obviously we want to do as
many videos as we can but there's
probably a lot of unanswered questions
that we may not get to for a while so
it's really cool to see you know people
we don't even know actively going in and
answering questions for curious minds
out there yeah do you have like do you
feel like you have a backlog of as far
as to do for the channel do you feel
like oh you know you have so much things
you want to do but you know not at the
time I wouldn't say not enough time I
would say like hopefully eventually you
know I can see this going for a long as
long as the interest is there we'll
hopefully have the privilege to keep
doing it
so we definitely are sort of logging all
of the ideas that pop up that we think
are really great and you know lots of
comments get tons of thumbs up and then
it kind of gives us the indication that
lots of people want to know about that
thing in particular um but then there's
also just things that we know that
people wouldn't necessarily ask right so
there's some cool factoids and things
that we've learned through a degree and
just from you know learning about
different science aspects that we think
it's hard to ask you know particular
things I can't think we're in this
example on the top of my head but some
of the videos we do somebody wouldn't
say for example how can you see the Big
Bang you know through a television or
radio that's something that you know we
have to let them know that they can
actually do sort of thing whereas it's
easier for someone to say hey can you
give us scientific weight loss tips so
there's two angles that we try and come
from the sort of high demand things as
well as the kind of behind the scenes
that we know that is really interesting
very good very good so I mean it's like
a you know it's you know it's a
combination of some requests and some
ideas that you and your you and your
your partner in this channel I've
already come up with are do you do you
or your partner with the channel Greg
Brown do you guys have any in spurring
characters they're inspiring to you any
people in the scientific community that
you guys kind of draw inspiration from
the kind of uh that are trying to
promote just a general awareness of
science and and hopefully to to like
encourage any young people
that might want to consider maybe taking
a career in the scientific field well
there's definitely there's kind of two
levels of the sort of scientists that
like we love and and there's popular
scientists like Bill Nye or Neil
deGrasse Tyson that are kind of out in
the public fronting this sort of you
know get get science out to the public
you know make it accessible to people
it's not just in a lab out it's not in
scienter NAL's that you know people
don't really understand how to find or
to read but they're kind of bringing it
to the forefront but it also say we've
been massively inspired by other
youtubers who are doing similar things
so there's people like the vlogbrothers
who have their crash course channel and
they have you know different history
channels that they're running and you
know people like that that have kind of
really been inspiring to us to see them
grow a community and they kind of
directly influenced us going about
making a community in the same way so
while they may not be necessarily
scientists like at the forefront of a
particular field they're definitely you
know science enthusiasts who love what
they're doing and they found an amazing
way to connect with people so right yeah
you know that's like that's a good point
you know it's not exactly like hard
science figures that can still be
inspirational they're all you know for
that subject though so I think that's a
really interesting point excuse me as
far as now you're on YouTube is there
any other places that uh like the
audience watching right now these that
uh you could direct them to you or do
you guys have a website obviously on
social media like Twitter and Facebook
yeah other platforms that you're on it's
it's basically surrounding YouTube right
now we've only been are like doing it
for about four months now and that we
saw that as a platform that you know the
like NFI with it's easily shareable and
if we thought if we could have sort of
one central location instead of you know
putting our videos all over different
platforms it might be easier for people
to understand that it is kind of a
weekly program we put up one video a
week in this same spot you can come and
watch it each week having said that
there's lots of other websites that you
know asked us if they can put our videos
at and we sort of try and you know
promote it and share to different
websites and send out email blasts and
stuff like that
but generally it's like a YouTube embed
so it all kind of links back to this
sort of hub and then yeah we have
Facebook and Twitter as just sort of
places for people to connect with us and
make sure they're updated if they you
know have it pop up in their Facebook
sort of timeline or YouTube subscription
box so there's lots of ways to kind of
stay connected but ultimately it's kind
of YouTube's object YouTube is you know
it is it's a really great way to share
just it sees its ease of or ease of use
for sharing information is really really
good and then I want to ask you you know
with our site we're always trying to
kind of give it a bison any
up-and-coming content creators you know
especially on YouTube and you know do
you find you have what is most difficult
about creating original content and
YouTube channel and is there any advice
you could give to any anybody that might
you know aspire to create their own
content through YouTube hmm I guess the
first aspect is to be prepared to just
work really hard I think a lot of times
when you put the work and you get it out
we we got really lucky and have over the
last couple of months got a lot of
attention but it really did take sort of
a base of just putting videos out and at
first they don't get many views and you
just kind of have to be consistent and
we've also just sort of found that
people you've got to find sort of your
nation how you can entertain people some
things are gonna work and some things
aren't and and so you know get out there
and experiment with your style and don't
be afraid to change it but also don't
let that limit you to when you start
don't just keep saying oh it has to be
perfect before I start because it can
evolve over time
like any good television show or you
know TV series or anything like if you
look at the beginning episode or the
first pilot it's drastically different
from the end so a lot of people can
sometimes be stunted by their own
perfectionism just get out there start
making videos if you're actually
passionate about it and you want to do
it because you care about education
specifically or science or whatever it
may be that you want to do on YouTube I
think if you really care about it if
that will come across if it's not
superficial and you know if it's not
because you want to be famous on YouTube
or something
I think people are pretty good at
reading motives behind different
channels on YouTube and so it's really
important that you have that right moto
that people will understand directly so
I guess that would be my advice I'm
trying to think of any other but I just
stick it out it's hard to get noticed we
do a lot of work and just trying to
connect with different websites and
bloggers and things like that who have
been super supportive of us and we're
definitely thankful for that but yeah
trying to become part of the community
make sure you're on Facebook Twitter you
know following the other youtubers and
stuff like that I think that'll add to
sort of the entire community and you can
all kind of feed off of each other yeah
definitely I mean personally I'm really
under real fan of the videos you guys
are making I've always been you know
I've always enjoyed science-based you
know programs in any form and I just
think you know you guys are really
original and I like the work you're
doing
thank you welcome are there you know is
there anything you want to say directly
to the people they're gonna their
viewing this video right now as far as
comment about getting in contact or I'm
sorry I'm kind of participating with you
or interacting to help we're always open
to people contacting us anyone can email
us at ASAP science at gmail.com whether
it be for suggestions or you know if you
are a scientist and you're interested in
working with us or you know you're in
that field and you want to be part of it
somehow we have a translation sort of
team that we've been building up of
people from around the world who are
interested in that so if you're
interested in translating any of our
videos and kind of helping us on that
front we'd be more than happy to you
know hear from you and yeah just in
general I'm constantly checking our
messages or Facebook and things like
that and we are listening to people and
taking ideas and stuff so anyway that
anybody wants to be involved we're happy
to hear it in terms of kind of where
it's going we would love to be more
involved with other people in the
science community including you know the
hardcore sort of actual Laboratory of
science scientists and maybe one day
we'll be able to sort of work more in
that field and bring to light other
scientists work you know that's kind of
where we see this going how it could
have like a real effect in this
world but yeah we're totally open to
working with anyone and hearing from
anyone great well I mean thank you so
much for just taking the time for this
interview
I really appreciate it and yeah I mean I
wish you guys luck and I hope you get
the channel really gross thank you very
much
all right take care of man have a good
one I think you bye